une empreinte de main à côté de celle
des autres maîtres du bellay de la
martinique
le cercle des maîtres compte désormais
neuf piliers des mémoires vivantes de la
tradition comme victor greif soixante
dix huit ans bien connu grâce à son
titre mibel joulin vendu à plus de 12
mille exemplaires c'est qui ça embête
bellay la vie au cou c'est aux yeux à la
vue de la très très plaisir
la vague il ya dans ce la ville mois
mais les membres de la maladie tout
comme - oui le monde à 85 ans julien
saab on a lui aussi rejoint le cercle
des mecs baylet poto mitan du groupe b
les basques pointent le natif de mende
ballet a toujours oeuvré pour la
transmission de la tradition pour les
membres de son groupe ce titre de maître
baylet est une façon de dire merci au
vieil homme
enfin moment qu'il est dans la galère
donc c'est vrai qu'il était au départ la
basse m'interpeller descendu à tivoli et
ça fait un moment qu'il transmet j'ai eu
la chance de le côtoyer donc il nous a
transmis le savoir et on a eu l'occasion
de discuter et pour nous donc ça pour
moi ça représente beaucoup et meteab
considéré comme un pilier de la
tradition martiniquaise gros gardien de
la tradition les mecs baylet sont aussi
des noms gravés dans le patrimoine des
figures emblématiques à faire connaître
aux plus jeunes et puis 15-15 l'année
mark a fait plaisir mais la transmission
est donc comme comment ce qu'a dit mon
cap à l'est souvent dilemme est belle
est donc sa cape ermite -10 vraiment
montrer ki moun ki moon juillet après 16
en deux piliers de la tradition sont
venus agrandir le cercle des medleys de
la martinique
la maison du bèlè espère d'autres
cérémonies d'intronisation dans les mois
à venir